It's,
that's what's so crazy is that things are so fucking blurry.
It's hard to see the troll sometimes.
Oh yeah.
And so there in lies the big problem.
I mean,
my brother might be one of the most notorious,
not notorious the wrong word,
because he,
he liked kind of hides in the shadows,
but he's done.
Some of my brother cloned a w,
I can't remember which website.
He cloned a website,
right?
The actually the,
yes man recently did this low,
I can post copied perfectly.
And he wrote an article about how a new strain of marijuana was discovered.
Cannabis Australia's.
He said that he was the dean at the University of Sydney or something like that.
Who was dating Popstar Meghan trainor.
Just the most ridiculous thing.
And that he said,
we need to find a female plant.
So far,
this what we have,
it's groundbreaking.
It's so,
so he did this very clever,
very clever thing.
He bought a domain name that was something like calm-guest.info.
That's the URL.
He then created a sub domain.
So it's like,
you know,
just hypothetically cnn.com dash gassed.
The average person just see cnn.com right.
They assume it's real.
I don't know how he shared it,
but he,
he makes this whole,
it's all ridiculous man.
I got to say if you thought it was real,
I got a bridge to sell you high times,
picked it up.
It got 50,000 shares.
Breakthrough new strain of marijuana.
Discovered.
My brother was just laughing the whole time and I was like,
what did you do?
Like my brothers,
like my opposite,
you know,
I try to be honest to the best of my ability I you can,
I think,
you know,
people accused me of being a liar.
That's not fair.
I could be wrong for sure,
but I try my best to be rational.
My brother on the other hand is like editing videos,
making them ridiculous as possible.
He made another video where it's crazy cause he tries to make sure people,
it's over the top.
He made a video where it's a van getting pulled over.
It looks like a police Dash Cam.
And then the cop walks up to the car,
checks the guy's license,
walks back,
and then the driver releases pot on a balloon and then an air points.
So it saying stash,
like he's disposing ms drugs with helium balloon.
So they fly away and then the cop runs up firing guns at it.
This thing got hundreds of millions of views.
It was on Facebook every other day.
It's,
it was like he made it four years ago or something and I saw it on Instagram
like two weeks ago and I was like,
dude.
And I showed him,
people think it's real.
Like it's,
it's the craziest,
but he,
he,
you know,
yeah.
I don't know.
So,
so much fucked up stuff that is real.
It's so hard to differentiate.
What I mean,
hold on.
Like let's,
let's throw some shade at high times.
Like when they did this,
you,
they said they,
they,
when they corrected the article and saying it was a hoax,
they said we wanted to call for a verification,
but we thought the story was too hot to pass up.